the reunion was fun though like they
want the one time we did it snow games
really good yeah man that was really fun
it was fun yeah yeah you ever think you
doing it on Netflix or
how many people on Twitter now just say
that just I feel like they're just doing
to annoy me thank God when people do
seriously bring it up to me like some
people still do like you got to bring
that show back it's like I'll say it one
more time you [ __ ] idiot I don't have
the power to bring go to HBO shut your
[ __ ] mouth
I did text Colin after and say that we
should do a few live shows because that
was really good and it was fun it was
really easy yeah why'd you choose to
take that off the air you know here's
the text I sent to Colin it was it was a
12:30 1:00 a.m. like a Night Live oh
yeah Nite Owl
I know we've discussed it but we really
should consider doing a couple of live
shows somewhere tough Crowley Union
shows maybe a thousand seat or 600 this
could definitely generate interest and
it would be not be hard for all of us it
would not be hard for all of us to sign
up and do it it would be so much more
fun than booking a theater show and just
doing one hour standing you just say we
could all share a market it was it'd be
fun to do with the guys did you get a
response 7:30 the next night I'm on the
crashing set around the corner nothing
nothing now in fairness Colin may have
been in bed for getting up for an early
call but I did then he had the whole day
the next day yes my next point yeah that
was Part A Part B was he did have the
next day but he responded to you so you
can see the text above when you're
writing a text I knew that yes Emmett my
my contempt for entrepreneurial Jimmy
came through yes
Jim's like you know if we did a thousand
say it's just I hate people that say
[ __ ] that I obviously like that never
occurred in my head like what I could do
it though and well you said that we
should go out you said I should I was
being polite yeah I know we should we
should do that we get a few guys and go
out and do it I think it'd be fun to see
if it means anything why not it really
is part is that you're about you're
about sick of these cousins he knows
right you get a
few topics would ever go to a live shall
we do a [ __ ] hour and 50 is already
producing yeah get a couple of set but
the segments were a little harder they
let's do a couple live shows let's put
it together
have you thought about doing it on
YouTube well if you do it if you do a
couple of live shows and people like it
and go to it then maybe that's a way to
do it
no of course but I've you know let's do
it a couple live shows use the music I
don't think so
why not I'd be fun you got your own live
shows to worry about don't you well I my
own shows to worry about it and I just I
don't know I just feel like no I don't
know maybe I'll think about it
yeah we do a couple of uh what book two
or three I mean I mean I'll do it for a
weekend I was a Friday Saturday I was
watching once again thank you there's
another T once ignited warm tea just you
infuriated that he goes we'll do it for
a week on Thursday Friday Saturday like
that's like a groundbreaking comedic
idea well I'm trying to you know lead us
into getting these show Saturday comedy
night I can't do Sunday cuz radio would
you not have thought of that
no so let's do let's do a couple of
weekends look a couple of you could do
it they said it like a boardroom table
or something right no you can't because
I don't minimalize are tough crowd
reunion tour yeah I'm trying to maximum
[ __ ] table does he mean no he said we
could discuss this in a boardroom table
oh you don't need to do it on the air
right now he's like what do we do like a
Thursday you wanna do Thursday and he
does nothing up a good point because
when we try to do it off the air we
don't get texted back he brings up a
terrible point Oh cuz I wasn't ramped
yet he's on the set of crashing sorry
Judd was giving me notes
that's all I love that you're like we
should bring back the show you created
yeah I was like don't have time for that
I'm hanging out with Judd well Colin
wants to bring it back on some level
because we talked about it was very fun
all of us were very sad at the end of it
it felt good we enjoyed it you know we
want to do it again
of course he does that was quite a
compelling argument yeah it was we
enjoyed it we'd um we miss Patrice and
you know Greg right but it was still fun
to do it was fun everybody misses it
just your sales pitch alone makes me not
want to do it just and food is you're
talking
it was the most cliche horrible as funny
as Norton is as original and far
and distinctive his he is hate when he
tries to be like a businessman it's the
most banal boring you're not wrong but
however lack of a Norton's norton
sincerity is but just the fresh ideas he
comes up with
it'll be enjoyable Thursday Friday
Saturday I'm trying to sell an idea mmm
I'm not good at it no but afterwards we
were all enjoying it so much and you
even said yeah we can you know you you
were caught up in the moment and yes and
then I then I try to propel us and go
let's book a couple of gigs and I get no
response now I have to go back into my
sales pitch I did try to propel us in
that moment no you that's fair
I just feel going back to I mean that
may be some incarnation of something
because I love the spontaneity of that
day but back to the well it just seemed
feel sad to me to go back and go hey
tough crowd
well just do it and how about think but
let's play well let's do a home grub not
happening ok forget for life tough crowd
tour is not happening you got a hard no
all right I tried
you got a hard pass yeah fans I tried
it's on the record you tried you got a
hard pass yeah you guys why is fun yes
it was about Colin I just have one
suggestion bringing tough crowd back
podcast you ever thought about that
Colin yeah so no podcast then why no loo
I'm sorry okay I don't know I just Nick
and Detroit has it figured out all right
he's got the business figured out
something we haven't thought of Nick hey
how's it going boys have you ever tried
this like Vegas or like Hulu or one of
those other oh that's an idea it's not a
bad idea
what about Hulu the most infuriating I
hope you'd be an ironic Nick
no I meant to I know I think it's a good
idea to lose our great what about Hulu
have you thought of that
how about Amazon Oh TV now let me give
everybody reality kasher every listening
right now right there is no network no
place no screaming no nobody would do a
show correctly and be
brutally honest those days are over you
too but let us do it YouTube bread or
whatever yeah we can do it somewhere
no what about wood what about Infowars
let's just let me just explain what's
gonna happen on a tour first of all
everybody we're not went out of we were
15 years ago that's true right a little
older a little wiser a little wiser but
everybody's a little bit more of a
[ __ ] diva - so it was gonna be like
wait a minute
it's gotta be like this so we're gonna
have to have a couple of assistants to
take care of all the little minutia [ __ ]
that we always take care of ourselves
right now that's okay yeah I'm booking
transportation okay let's go to Philly
okay we show up in Philly
everybody wants a hotel room right yeah
that's six seven hotel rooms sure now we
have the venue we who's gonna take us to
the menu promoter will promote hold on
promoter yeah one word manager a guy
like Kenny if he can do it he takes care
of all travel in hotel rooms he
coordinates with everybody simple why
does he tell the promoter homey without
problem we need a van to take us to the
venue the promoter has a vested interest
in getting the performers to the venue I
got a better idea
they will get us to the venue I could
simplify this process it's totally worth
every film it with Kenny okay Nick I'm
telling you but that's very simple stuff
we all get a hotel pickup we all go to
the [ __ ] venue we do the show we come
back and then we do what we want if
we're driving we all drive home
separately or we also here's a [ __ ]
hotel room nobody cares
there's Ryu you want to avoid all that
you do the tough crowd tour you bring
back tough crowd hosted by Colin Quinn
here are my guess Nick Mullen Joe list
mark Normand and Tim Dylan oh yeah
that's tough crowd that's that's the way
the proud new blood tour yeah that's
that's what you go hundred percent right
tough crowd the new blood you're right
yeah I'm ready now
right that's what was holding me back
that him you know yeah these [ __ ]
these divas these writers on your on
your ankle it's not gonna happen
exactly no Stavros exactly exactly my
idea we'll go to Philly oh my god exams
idea better yeah which get some new
blood I don't like that idea it's a new
blood I don't like that
they seen the old one you know it's Sam
Morrow [ __ ] damn yeah yeah Morell a
man who's better than Dan soda for oh my
god a dead spot get Dan Soder in do all
the voices and everything s charming
girls like him knocks yeah imagine what
Joe Mackie will come up with yes
you know Sam morale is just throwing
[ __ ] at Joe Mackie Joe Mack he's
throwing it right back I'd go to that
show you'd hate it you hate their
podcast energy you'd hate it makes their
common bond podcast energy will give you
had Nick in stand and Stavros or if you
had Joe and and Sam Earl anybody who
does a podcast together big J - this and
Dan together you get Nick Mullen you
have to know from different podcasts
Nick Mullen Stavros Joe Mackey Sam Morel
you call it tough crowd battle the
podcast War of the castes yeah yeah
caste war you'd hate it about this guy
cops crowd we get those guys and just
Nick DiPaolo
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
clever clever [ __ ] line I love the
idea I think we're gonna do it I'm gonna
love the idea Sam has done more to
destroy the idea then I love it I think
I think I think we're all on the same
page now
Joe in New York great idea no in new Joe
yeah well you're speaking to all of you
yes okay looking first service compound
media he's not throwing your ass off
okay tough crowd on compound media are
we signed yes we've heard that I've
heard that you have yeah but um well you
know he's right
they're the one place it wouldn't throw
it off they would never throw it off now
no so why not do it well you two
wouldn't throw it off I mean it's just
guys big furniture because I don't know
I'm just not I mean I just can't imagine
doing it as a show as a regular show but
we try it a couple of times a couple of
live time we try if it doesn't work we
don't that we don't release it we don't
like it we don't release it yeah so
worse that happens you get a couple of
wires show but if people see in front of
a live venue
and it's killing and it's funny and it's
an hour wood of me only were actually a
half hour with we [ __ ] do it you know
how [ __ ] do it for a we don't like we
don't do it for a week yeah yeah I'll be
honest bring out my cannon the young
guys even the one even the one thing
that I liked which was like the
improvisation skill Nate from San
Francisco [ __ ] ruined that when I
started calling us an improv show when
he started calling you whose line a
modern-day whose line well you were
selling at his improv well this would be
great though you go out lame date now no
you were saying your favorite thing was
that was improv so Nate was just trying
to run with that you were the one 98 was
trying to destroy me with that crowd
tour okay and it becomes a big success
you just watch within a year you're
hosting let's make a deal you're fine
for the drew Carey you're doing [ __ ]
car commercials yeah I mean I have to
navigate around a tough crowd really
happened the first tough crowd around I
remember his out diluted I was about
that show when it first happened they
were replacing Craig Kilborn on or not
before no job was already in there who's
that Late Show before Craig Ferguson I'm
saying no I'm too late stupid Chuck you
know that Late Show the James J whiskey
was Craig guilty warrant and then
somebody's guy right and I was like
they're getting Ferguson they're gonna
ask me obviously I'm gonna turn it down
I said they're gonna beg me to George I
just did tough crowd they're gonna
obviously want somebody's hosts tough
crowd was over tough crowd was just
ending I was like and that show was just
getting a new host and what were they
saying to you like what broke down those
negotiations they literally they showed
their list of people that were it was
like 15 names my name wasn't even one of
them I was like what you didn't make the
top 15 and make the top the just a
speculation idea that were you shocked I
was I thought for sure seven host
perfect show how am I gonna do it
because it's in LA and I really want to
do that right now for me right now you
really never even was even considered it
was their presenting as not Herschel
never got nobody wanted to anything to
do a tough crowd
tough crowd was in many ways a you know
like I said one of the things about it
you know we could have done things
different but one of the things about it
was it's everything that people claim
they want
yeah she's authentic honest spontaneous
honest stuff that where you're watching
TV be like oh these guys are without a
net like they're really saying whatever
is coming up they're not preparing to
make sure it's funny sometimes you bomb
your bomb you get called out on it
including even the host especially the
host yeah yeah but uh but yeah it was in
the long run people say they want things
until they see them yeah and and they
try everybody says they want you know
like this alternative to what's on
television and that was an alternative
to what was on I think that's the idea
for a tough crowd we could have guys
with liberal ideas on one side and
conservative ideas on the other side
it's a good idea actually an even better
idea Jack in New Jersey has a good
thought what's up Jack hey Colin how
about having a tough crowd float in the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade we're all
just teasing each other from corner to
corner Pilgrims and Indians tried a lot
of [ __ ] and tinker's and each one will
have a mic and they can walk along
beside the float and confront people on
issues they love it and Colin is in the
middle he's dressed as the turkey like
what do you want for me we all had the
[ __ ] headdresses on Patrice in a big
dumb Indian headdresses Nick that was
not helpful because it would build a
nice buzz the show must be coming back I
remember that show he's right it would
be a good bus right right imagine all
the people I guess all these like nice
soccer moms know what's going on with
this good-naturedly poking fun of each
other keeping it clean because we're on
the float too much corn bread last night
I helped themselves to the stuffing
algorithm oh my god there's the tough
crowd float yeah we have like a special
sign made up tough crowd check out these
turkeys it could be good yeah that was
really unhelpful oh so when in Philly we
have to coordinate our schedules take a
night call if I was running this joint
record schedules because there's there's
yourself Nick Keith Bobby
me voice there's six of us so how would
we do it because you can't leave anybody
else no women on the show that's a good
point I get Judy gold maybe and Bonnie
was never on though was she she was
that's where she met her betrothed there
is traumatic memories yesterday she's
dark in the doorway and bad boys go hey
this guy's kind of cute
oh yeah get Bonnie and Judith alright
you know I didn't think of that yeah but
I understand for the first episode I
wasn't thinking of the diversity six
people are not gonna fit on the first
episode nine oh but this guy we used to
tag-team people and how do you do that
right that's it then the episode it
could used to be thirty minutes on TV so
it was a 22 minute episode but if we're
doing an hour having two other guys
might help you're not a TV producer the
way your to do what your voice is really
annoying me right now however minutes
it's a 30-minute episode we do twenty
two minutes so it's not a thirty minute
it's a 22 minute episode mommy on TV
it's a live show
shut up Colin knows I'm right he doesn't
like the fact I don't like the way his
hands all right now exactly what you
said call they're exactly the content
exactly the same by the way look at
Colin's hands your fingers are
interlaced we play the past two minutes
of him talking yeah I hear a guy doing a
bad impression of a network exec you
know what you can here's a 50 year old
man that's trying to avoid the belt
who's like come on guys let's go out
there and do it gay right well actually
there are some fun there are some
helpful ideas very good oh wow on Staten
Island Oh God Sal you there instead of
going to Philly why don't you guys go to
matchmaking it and you could film in the
pfg studios with scores what do you
think if we got scorched a broadcast
union that could actually do I love
what's your thought ever what about this
yeah y'all learnt the biggest comedian
of all time Kevin Hart right what won't
you go to him you have to be on the left
out how network yes no you know what the
lol Network is one thing but will be
worse than me as a businessman is Kevin
as a mogul making a decision
none of us want to go in and look at
Kevin at a table scratching his chin
debating whether or not he'll hand us
our careers but we really enjoy it
good point nine of our $800 sneakers for
this feet up is little feet up I love
you all I love you out and shut nobody
wants that yes I would love some money
Kemp
I'd rather [ __ ] die in the TLA and
filly in front of 300 people because no
one's interested exactly okay we don't
what you love cash give her some cash
come that's a damn good idea the lol
Network yeah it's not a bad idea but
[ __ ] good idea it would be putting
Kevin and sharks have an in charge it's
okay how it goes there's no way around
it it's yeah it's good to have a hey
he's under him then some idiot doesn't
get comedy I just gave you all these
ideas to really put a kickstart into
your career you guys gave me the only
buddy came up with a [ __ ] idea was
Tyrell from Tennessee yes sure Eleazar
fool but however yeah it was me nudging
huh somebody was elbowing you and
needling you the entire show I brought
it back up and shook the ridicule and
then took the ridicule like a big boy
acting like it's on the air it's not
gonna happen it's gonna know but we're
gonna we're gonna do we're gonna do
one's live shows in Germantown
Pennsylvania we're gonna do it
Philadelphia and maybe one of the place
Kevin's gonna film it that's right he's
gonna probably want more money that we
want to give him and then he's gonna put
it on lol I'm telling you that's a great
idea and I hate that we didn't think of
it but ah you know I'm glad we didn't
think of it because he would have poo
pooed it he would have what do you wanna
say just because Tyrell came up with it
I know because we all heard it
spontaneously together you didn't have
time to poopoo it because we were all
hearing it and equally excited are you
excited Colin no yes he is he's excited
I've got it make a tough crowd app do
you ever think about that making it make
your own app well you can write in in
the winner of the day gets us to tease a
topic right right apps are big they are
apps are real big you could put it on
your phone on you could even put it on
your iPad I don't like the way you just
shot down the reunion idea I think the
idea of the tour will be fun now you
doesn't want to do it he doesn't want to
play gigs he's doing one in every crowd
make the money you get more than us
we'll split the right you know come on
no it's not about the money I know
Damone a do it in [ __ ] Philly maybe
start it and film you thought about that
Philadelphia you don't drive it there's
no airfare no hotels if we don't want
on his driving distance if we did do it
Philly would be the place to do yeah
right it would be [ __ ] fun you know
and it would be you know we get us all
together me you Nick
Dave actually maybe Bob it even better
than doing it live Dave San Francisco
has an idea what's that Dave yeah I
think it's Nate from San Francisco I
think you guys should do a live show in
all the major cities like New York San
Francisco Philly and you can make make a
compilation on Netflix I've been a huge
fan for a long time see I think I think
seeing both sides of an argument was
what made that show great it wasn't just
all controversial negativity because you
had Patrice yelling at people with
different ideas and it was just the best
show on TV at the time it was very
honest you know the here race discussed
between Nick and Patrice well and
everybody being funny and honest up and
you know there was times Patrice was
would win and there was times Nick would
win or Geraldo would win everybody
wanted everybody lost points now that's
what the fun part of was it was it was
just an honest on a show what have you
filmed we did the tough crowd live show
you filmed it and then you put it at vas
roast comm one idea that is the gorgeous
Berg edgy underground things
[Laughter]